ausverkauft nach wenigen minuten
hygieneartikel und desinfektionsmittel
die der discounter aldi am montag als
aktionsangebot in den regalen hatte
schon vor ladenöffnung um 8 uhr bildeten
sich schlangen vor den filialen können
und die produkte waren schnell
vergriffen
generell das ist glaube ich gut war
krankheiten dass man sich die hände
damit ab und zu mal ein spiel nicht
vergesst das oft genug aber ich glaube
das hilft schon klar also zumindest was
die übertragung schnelligkeit geht dass
das jetzt irgendwie die ausbreitung
verhindert das glaube ich ehrlich gesagt
nicht aber vielleicht ein bisschen
langsamer und jedesmal händewaschen
intensiv und mehr kann man ja nicht tun
jahrelang haben sich gegen die
schweinegrippe ist interessiert ok wird
so der neue purismus übertrieben
nach aussagen von aldi stand die aktion
nicht im zusammenhang mit corona und
trotzdem um hamsterkäufen vorzubeugen
durfte jeder kunde nur drei produkte
kaufen